the most accurate biopic about the Great
Wall of China ever made not might be fun
no they look great
Wow to the grave all-stars Matt Damon it
takes place in a time of legend Matt
Damon and Prince Oberyn from Game of
Thrones camping of his name don't know
his name there were a couple of
scoundrels they're looking for black
powder which we know that gunpowder and
there's some at this great wall they go
to the great wall even the great wall
there's a huge army defending the land
against big Komodo dragon things that
attack the wall in waves and so they get
kind of sucked into this war so now you
have a movie about battles not going to
lie though for the first part of the
river section of this movie this set up
I actually really enjoyed it I really
did I love seeing the army different
armor represents different factions of
this army that defends the wall against
these big evil lizards their formation
that colors the visual appeal all of it
it reminded me of the elves from Lord of
the Rings defending helms deep on a much
larger scale
it is really look cooler something
majestic about all of it the battle is
happening I'm like oh my god I'm
actually enjoying this can it be so
look man having a good time in the great
wall but then the movie starts to trip
over its own dick when the movie is
forced to rely on that which does not
have depth and that is the characters
seriously when the battle dies out like
all right now we have to rely on Matt
Damon and it's interesting this young
general girl like you I'll give him that
he's interested in her and then his
partner is kind of like hey we still
want the black-powder Blum's of hosing
this movie for god knows what reason but
the moment you gotta flip a switch to
care about the characters and the set up
note starts to fail I was counting my
yawns I got yawns 9 times in this movie
just when the battles aren't going down
you're like oh my god oh my god it slows
down to a crawl you don't really care
about it the story if you just look at
the story it's interesting story you
just kind of ask and roll comes looking
for money and then he kind of finds a
reason to live yet all he's known all
his life is lower in battle and instead
of fighting for a paycheck he has
something worth fighting for like Rambo
said in food doesn't look good and
that's enough for him I kind of a
constant interest during execution note
a negative ghostrider then the last act
of this movie hits in the last act is
really choppy
I promise you there's more to that last
act than we saw these movies
supposed to be some three-hour effort
and everything we saw in the first two
thirds of the movie was actually what
was supposed to be in the last act
shaped about an hour off of it like they
got to go do the same and they go do
this thing and then this thing is now in
the capital city then this person that
was going that way then goes that way
they zig and then these I'm really
trying to be back as on its boiling
point is the waste editage makes it look
like people have teleportation
a little side quest says yeah willem
dafoe doesn't matter guys and the end I
can only tell you the end is ultimately
like if you wire a bunch of bombs to a
car you're like all right I'm going to
roll this car down the roads going to go
right next to that guy I got a kill then
I'm going to shoot the fuse light the
car blow the car up it's going to blow
the dude up or when you shut the car you
could have just shot the dude no need to
wire up a car I don't know why you did
guys in the end the great wall very
mixed bag but not great the first part
of the movie was interesting the setup
was good I liked seeing the soldiers on
the wall who in that first 20 minutes is
done the movie grind down to a crawl and
even when the little skirmishes started
happening after the biggest battle in
the entire movie which is the first
battle doesn't really pick up and then
the last act of the movie is just
shopping it's like they took that thing
slices up and they were like you out
here we're out of time here's the movie
I will say the great walls yeah you're
not going to remember it in t-minus one
day ya already forgot which is funny
because great wall is enormous the only
skirmishes seem to happen in this one
section I'm like alright so that
explains why that one mile of the wall
is Bill what about these are 5,000 plus
miles I don't know their armies just up
and down this wall in every moment of
every day that's a lot of miles of me
Bobby
take it for what it is alright guys are
the great wall I'm using it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]